one year ago today I uploaded a video to
YouTube about the difference between the
UK Great Britain and England at the time
of the upload I've been living in London
for about eight years and while I
understood the basics of this foreign
land I still had questions niggling at
the back of my mind about all the other
little pieces such as the isle of man
and jersey and guernsey
who weren't exactly part of the UK but
were still somehow British one day while
buying cream for my wife's coffee I was
confronted with this Jersey cows and
could no longer contain my irritation of
my own ignorance
what are you Jersey cows I wondered and
why is the Union Jack on here if you're
not part of the UK I went home to sort
this out for once in all of what I
expected it would take ten minutes but
as so often is the case when your
starting point is the Wikipedia ended up
becoming a research project involving
dozens of hours to not feel like I
completely wasted my time I turned it
into the video I eventually upload it to
YouTube I asked some locals what they
thought and soon was attacked by the
monster of viral videos fast forward to
today and I now find myself in the odd
position of being a socially reclusive
guy followed by a hundred thousand plus
people whose videos have been seen more
than 10 million times which is more than
a bit overwhelming if I think about it
too much but I want to say a huge thank
you to each and every one of you not
personally of course is reading a
hundred thousand-plus names at one
second each would take about 28 hours
but a general thank you thank you so
much for subscribing and watching and
sharing my videos I also want to thank
some youtubers who've helped me along
the way including minute physics and the
vlogbrothers and Phil DeFranco who in a
single week tripled my subscribers and
in particular I want to thank Michael
from Vsauce who was nice enough to meet
up with me in the physical world at the
London Googleplex which getting to see
the inside of made me feel 20% cooler
where he encouraged me to make videos on
a more regular schedule you dear viewer
may know one or more of these guys but
please subscribe to them all and
encourage YouTube cross-pollination I
don't know exactly where this channel is
going to go in the future but it's been
an interesting ride so far and if you
stay with me I sincerely hope to keep
making more stuff that you'll like
thanks again to all 100,000 of you